Mike is sealing up
the Oval Office
because there's a contagion
out there.
Fortunately, we're safe and
no one else is getting in.
DONALD JR. (nearby):
Is that you, dad?
What the... ?
-Don, Jr.?
-Oh.
Oh, no.
(electronic voice):
Outbreak not contained.
-Outbreak not contained.
-(siren wails)
Dad, there's an outbreak
that's not contained.
-Outbreak not contained.
-Turn that off! Turn it off!
-What the hell is wrong with
you? -Outbreak not contained.
You know that picture
where JFK, Jr., uh,
crawled out of the desk?
Everyone loved that.
So now they'll all love
little Don-Don.
You're hiding from
Robert Mueller, aren't you?
Busted.
Well, at least he's
being honest, sir.
That's my boy,
totally transparent.
Now sit down on the couch
and don't touch anything.
Now watch daddy tell everyone
what to do.
It's time for executive orders.
(cheering and applause)
First up, a huge iceberg
broke off of Antarctica
the same week that that psycho
Joe Scarborough broke away
from the Republican Party.
So executive order,
Joe Scarborough and the iceberg
have to trade places.
Scarborough has to live
in the South Pole,
and the iceberg has to sit next
to that bloody-faced,
low-IQ Mika.
(Donald, Jr. laughs)
Boy, you really hate women, Dad.
It's like if they won't have sex
with you you're all pissed,
and then if they do
have sex with you,
you'll lose respect for them
because they had sex with you.
It is a trip.
TRUMP:
Okay, all right, okay.
How about a little less
transparency, Don, okay?
Oh, yeah, yeah, no.
I'm chill.
Mike, why are you sitting
all the way down there?
You're not distancing yourself
from me and my family, are you?
Oh, no, no, sir,
of course not, no.
I'm happy to-- there we go.
Then why are you hosting
private meetings
with big Republican donors
at your residence?
This better not be what it
looks like, you albino worm.
What? No, sir, no, no.
I know what you're getting at,
but it has been
the honor of my life
to serve as your vice president,
sitting at your right hand
the way that Saint Peter
will sit next to...
Nice try, Mike, okay?
Executive order: no guys named
Mike from Indiana
who have never done cocaine
can be president.
PENCE:
Well, sir...
No, that's-that's not fair, sir.
Who says I'm talking about you?
I can pretend to be weird.
That's hilarious, Dad.
Because, at first,
Mike had no political future
without you.
And now he only has
a political future without you.
-Time is funny.
-Jesus!
This is why
we're in so much trouble.
Do you ever shut up?
Yeah. When you divorced Mom,
I shut up
and not talk to you
for a whole year.
Best year of my life.
Moving on.
This morning, Republican
senators released their new plan
for repealing
and replacing Obamacare.
And it still might not pass.
This thing is dying
a slow, gruesome death.
So, executive order:
we need to pass
a health care bill
for the health care bill.
Sure, it has
a preexisting condition.
Yeah, it sucks.
You suck!
Yeah, yeah, I suck.
But that's no reason
to deny it coverage.
We'll call it
the AHCAHCA,
or "a-cha-cha-cha-cha!"
It's so funny, 'cause it's not
even about health care.
Repealing Obamacare is all about
tax cuts for rich people
like us.
If we really cared about
lowering health care costs
we'd move
to a single payer system,
so we could negotiate
prices with providers.
Goddamn it, get back
under the desk right now!
Plus, the whole thing with
Obamacare was that a black guy
told us it do it
and we did not like that.
And then... and then you said
he was born in Kenya,
but you knew.
TRUMP:
No, no. No, no.
You knew
he wasn't born in Kenya.
No, I did not, I did not.
-I didn't know that.
-And you only ran for president
'cause you wanted to renegotiate
The Apprentice.
Zip it! Zip it!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, totally!
Remember when
you got all dressed up
to go to Chelsea Clinton's
wedding because you thought
you were invited, but you were
actually not invited at all?
Mike, will you stop him?!
Oh, no, you're upsetting
the president, please "stop."
DONALD JR.:
Oh, yeah, no, no, I-I will.
Remember when you came
downstairs naked that time
and your fupa got stuck
in the banister
and then we realized your pubes
look like Captain Crunch?
Enough!
You're a low-quality person.
You're a low-quality
person.
Well...
cat's in the cradle, Dad.
-PENCE: Ooh.
-No more transparency.
Executive order: